I'm not surprised.
I want to thank you because what was surprising about your electric today?
It was his concept of altruism.
I think you've been able to just put everything together and at the end come
with a higher value of altruism.
And to me it was a surprise.
You don't come in here and I have a relationship with altruism and the one that
I find it's difficult for me is that there's an evolutionary process of my
brain.
It's an organ is developed,
you know,
and,
and I'm amazed at how often I think of three people,
me and myself and I to the point where where I've actually written down counter
all of the iterations of me,
myself and I and either my thoughts or my speech or even in someone else's and
you'll get a page and saw them do we think of wheat as far as I've been able to
ascertain is because I have to expend energy to think about someone else.
And,
and,
and yet yet I'm addicted to ease and comfort because my natural evolution is
going to be some comfort.
And you hear it in,
in alcoholics anonymous.
Well,
booze ain't the problem.
You're addicted to ease and comfort.
How do I overcome my,
what I think is my sense of ease and comfort to be able to make altruism
a more natural state of being good.
Good,
good question.
So the question is,
the first was a comment about the emphasis in my talk today on altruism in the
second is how do I,
how do people overcome their proclivity to only act on their own behalf?
Okay.
So the first thing I will say is that I don't believe that what I spoke about
today was in favor of altruism.
And and I,
that's not a negative comment on your question,
but there,
so there's a,
there's,
there's a pro,
here's a primary religious injunction.
Treat the other person like you would like to be treated yourself.
That does not mean be nice to other people.
It does not mean sacrifice yourself excessively for other people it means think
about the other person has,
if they were you,
and figure out how you can mutually interacts to better both of you.
At the same time you have to build yourself into the equation.
It's an equation.
It's not that.
It's not that the others are more valuable,
it's that we're all valuable,
were equally valuable.
And then you think,
well how do you remind yourself of that?
And the answer to that is through terror because terror is the genuine
motivator.
So they save
fear of God is the beginning of all wisdom.
Well what does that mean?
It means first that you don't get away with anything.
And it's really useful to know that because if you really know that you won't
try to get away with while you still will because people are stupid but,
but at least it will mitigate the possibility.
So here,
I'll tell you something that young said,
this is quite,
this is quite profound and,
and it's,
I think the right answer to this question.
So young believed he was interested in the emergence of higher morality.
Uh,
something that the developmental psychologist,
Sean Piaget was also interested in.
Here's a thought.
We started out as individuals.
Then we learned to play games with other people,
kids,
children learn how to play games without the children.
And that made them social.
So our society is a game.
It's a giant game that we're all playing together voluntarily.
And so children were first learned how to play the game,
and only later did they learn the rules of the game.
And he learned how to play the game first and then learn the rules to how to
speak the rules.
And then at some point they realized that they were also creators of the rules.
And so that's moral development on a continual on a,
it's not a continuum,
it's,
it's a fractured staircase upward.
But young was interested in elements of moral action that were higher than that.
And so he conceptualized it symbolically.
So imagine this,
you did this in the last book he wrote called mysterium connectionists.
So imagine that you're exist so that your conceptual structures and your
emotions are an uneasy relationship with one another.
So you're sort of a house divided amongst yourself.
And so what you have to do is you have to put together your mind and your,
and your emotion so that they're working as a,
as a unit.
And you do that in part by actually being forthright about what it is that you
want for yourself and to other people.
And to learn how to negotiate that.
So that inner tension disappears.
And so now you're a unified,
you're a unified entity of emotion and thought they're not conflicting with one
another.
And then what you do is you take that entity,
which is still in some sense separate from your body because you're not acting
these out and you bring those two together.
And he thought about that as the psychological equivalent of the incarnation
had.
So it's integrated spirit integrating with the body.
And what that means is that you take your emotions and motivations and capacity
for thinking that are now one thing and you act out those things you.
So you embodied them in the world.
And that's another thing that brings integrity.
And then there was a step past out in the step past that is to understand that
there's no deal.
So you have the integrated spirit,
mind and body
in opposition to the world.
And this,
the next thing you do is realize that there is no opposition with the world.
Is that what you are as a,
and this is very,
very complicated.
You're walking down the street.
[inaudible] street is a good example of this in Toronto and they're decimated
alcoholic,
schizophrenia.
It's littering the landscape so to speak.
You walk around them,
you say,
well,
that's not me.
It's like,
yes it is.
It's you in so far as your tendency is to react in a negative way and to skirt
the territory.
It's,
it's a disturbance in your field of being.
It's you now,
you don't know what to do about it and I wouldn't recommend that you do anything
because you'd probably just make it worse.
It's a very big problem that's lying there on the sidewalk.
And it may be well beyond your capacity to fix it.
But in so far as it's a disturbance in your field of being,
it's you,
it's you and all the problems that are in the world that,
that you experienced there you,
and so you stop thinking about things in terms of an opposition between what's
good for you and what's good for the world because there is no difference.
There's no difference between the two.
And that that doesn't mean that the pathway from what's good for you in your
more limited domain to what's good for everyone is an easy one to compute.
It's very,
very difficult.
But there is no,
there is no technical difference between them,
you know?
So if I'm engaged in a psychotherapeutic dialogue with my clients when I'm doing
it properly,
it's not like they're learning from me.
It's that we're learning together.
And every time I solved one of their problems or help them solve one of their
problems,
I help myself solve one of my problems.
You know,
because people bring to me,
bring into my sessions the terrible things that go wrong with people in life.
Their partner has cancer,
their father's hasn't,
father has Alzheimer's,
they're suffering with alcoholism.
Their career is collapsing.
Like these aren't things that are happening to them.
These are things that happen to everyone.
And to figure out how to solve that for someone is to figure out how to solve it
for yourself.
There's no difference whatsoever.
And so,
and then so there's to know that,
to,
to think of that and certainly works in,
in an intimate relationship.
If you think that you're somehow different than your wife,
while certain she's going to remind you otherwise constantly.
But it's an,
it's an error.
It's an error because you're,
you're tied together so tightly that whatever happens to one inevitably happens
to the other.
And that's true in,
in the network reality that we all inhabit.
So then the,
the terror thing emerges when you start to realize that those problems that you
don't address that or may be magnified by your impulsive and foolishly self
centered and instrumental behavior,
you're manipulating the world on behalf of your own narrow interests.
Those,
we'll come back to haunt you.
And so it's a terrifying thing to think through.
But once you think through it and understand it,
then what happens is you're more afraid of acting selfishly,
then you are willing to do it.
You think,
no,
I'm not doing that.
Why?
Because I know all hell will break loose if I do that and I'm not going there.
And so the terror element has a huge one.
It makes it,
it,
it fortifies your cause you can't just act
properly.
You don't have the moral fortitude for that.
You can aim at the good and run from what's terrible,
then you're,
then you're motivated.
So
with your environment,
uh,
reaching out to your environment,
doesn't it,
that expenditure of energy rather as an investment?
Yes.
It's an investment.
That's a very good way of putting it.
Yes.